so you look at who they have left they
have joe biden
the the dude struggles okay he struggles
he's not going to be viable next they
couldn't do hillary clinton
there are no prominent democratic
figures
none if donald trump wins it's
over for them the establishment will be
talking about the military industrial
complex so
this is what i was thinking earlier i
think like you were saying lydia do we
go back to what it was before
before america was the world police i
think yeah
because i don't think having a world
poli one country be the world police
makes much sense anymore it's too much
pressure on the country
um but if america were to stop being a
world police would china just
fill that gap yes well for their own
interests yeah
is there a way to globalize a world
police so that
no nation takes control no thank you no
but there's mutually sure destruction
china doesn't want to go to war with us
and we're dangerously close as it is
so i think conventional war they're at
war with us on
every angle right now anyway i
i think that one of the contributing
factors as to why we're on the precipice
of war is because
of world policing yeah for sure we we
put precipice
of war with whom china no we're already
at war oh
yeah right right right we're already at
war i mean i mean conventional full hot
war
no that's done that that's not that's
not gonna happen we are currently
engaged in a fourth generation warfare
with
china they're pumping a country full of
drugs the same way we
pumped their country full of drugs in
the last century
they're taking over infrastructure and
trading routes all
over the world they're pumping us full
of freaking propaganda
they're running tick-tock and pushing
the algorithm to corrupt our youth
there's they're they're helping these
activists you know these collectivist
activists they're helping
on every front we are at war engagement
they're actually saying
themselves because that communist party
has co-opted the citizens they are not
the citizens don't want to do that stuff
but this
this party but they do and they're in
the military and they and they
contribute they control the military
that's authoritarianism but yes we are
we are we are in fourth generational
and and i believe that we need to be
more explicit about that one of the
reasons i voted for trump and it's in
the book
democrats are deplorable did i mention
that yes you wrote that i wrote a book
i wrote a book it's selling really well
too
uh the one of the things to talk about
is is changing the language and the
conversation
around china biden for so many years
ah china ah china starting back with the
wto in the 90s where we let them into
the world trade organization which was
protested by the way by
antifa and blackhawk which is funny
because they're anti-globalist
at the time yep we have started since
then just giving our country away to the
point now where
in a pandemic we didn't have all the
supplies and we had risks of drugs
running out and all kinds of bad things
that are happening
and so we need to actually be saying
china
and in the united states these are is an
antagonistic relationship right now
and we need to be changing the the
energy there and i think that that has
been
accomplished wasn't that that was the
battle in battle in seattle
yes that was the world trade
organization protests
leftists were shutting down streets in
opposition to global
trade policy right amazing how many of
these people
are now older and still part of the left
but in complete
a complete inversion to what they once
believed
and that's part of that's part of the
problem i see that
not only did i feel used by the
activists who are like vote for obama
vote for obama you know end the war and
then he made it worse and they walked
away
it's also them saying like hey look at
all these things that are really bad and
you know these trade policies look what
we're protesting i'm like great and then
years go by and they're like oh we we
flipped 180 on that one
dude you want to talk about being used
let's talk about gen x
gen x and race okay i'm 44 years old i
was raised by my culture and everyone
around me just to not see color
not see gender not see race sound like i
was saying nazi right
now race to not see any of these things
and to judge people on the content of
their character and we did all that
and we lived in that manner and then you
get to adulthood and what do they say
now
too bad dude you're a racist white
supremacy your color matters color
matters
they used us gen x they used us and
we're bitter
you know you know what triggers me a
whole lot about these people
the progressives are the ones who fought
for
uh loving v virginia ending
miscegenation laws
they have created generations of
mixed-race people for which they now
essentially disavow as either
bend the knee and be privileged or be
white so that's that's that's
i th these people i i think you know i
was talking to someone about robin
deangelo's book where she basically
she says i have no answer for how a
mixed-race person is supposed to
function
i don't know her exact quote but she
basically just like chugs it off
but in this woke world of like racial
discrimination you know like ibram
excandi and robyn d'angelo
they don't have a a a a a space
for people of mixed race that the
progressives actually you know
created the laws which allowed these
generations to flourish and exist
now their create not now the left is
embracing
these these policies and ideas that
essentially say
okay all of one race here all of one
race here oh this one's both what do we
do
so that that to me is particularly
offensive it's like you're the activists
right now claiming you cared about these
things you cared about the dream of
martin luther king jr
and now you're holding up signs with his
quotes on it while fighting against his
dream
i can fully support you man with the gen
x thing i'm 41 and i basically caught
the tail end of gen x
raised with the exact same ideals we are
all the same not
not identical but man you look past what
you see
yeah and that's who we were unity you
know and then i went to occupy wall
street
and was ready to talk about the
constitution was told
we're not having any more white people
speak you can't speak to the news we
have too many white people
exactly too many white people that i
saw that written on a board at my
last job that i got fired from when i
got doxed by antifa
and they fired me for being announced i
got canceled
but while i was there on the whiteboard
that was the note-taking for the
diversity inclusion and equity committee
they wrote on the board literally too
many white people
working here how's that legal it's not
it's totally illegal
it's totally illegal it's a violation
it's a hostile work environment it's a
violation of my civil rights
and when you when i spoke up about it
i get fired yeah gosh and so now in
california as most people who are
watching probably know because i bring
it up all the time
the democrats are trying to repeal the
civil rights passage in their
constitution
and they call it the affirmative action
bill so then when i try talking to
people they're like but it's for
affirmative action i say oh can you
point to the language in the bill that's
prefer affirmative action
what do you mean it says affirmative
action it's the title it's antifa oh so
if i make a bill called the patriot act
it's for for being a patriot yeah that
whole part about locking people up and
definitely you know and and all that
stuff that's that's
that's patriotism that's exactly it
it's it's you know you know what's
really remarkable about the modern left
is
the semantic tools they use to
manipulate
low information voters we are
anti-racist
therefore if you oppose us you're a
racist now anti-racism holds the exact
same tenets of racism
but the name is different you know it's
like it's like we're anti-racist
we didn't say we're not we just you know
yeah just call it something else
anti-fascism well they're violent
authoritarians
not technically fascists clever you know
i have a
belief this might be a little esoteric
but i think that the human mind is not
logical it's more emotional so when you
say
yes double negatives they don't
translate properly to the human
totally so if i say don't be evil
they're hearing
don't be evil and they're hearing be
evil
even though i said don't before it so
when you're saying anti-fascist
you're putting out the fascist energy
and so it's making these people
that way well they're they're fascistic
they're not fascist right and
what that means is they use a lot of the
same tactics
and they hold many similar ideologies
but on core components they're not
fascist like they're not nationalists
they're not traditionally what is
fascism anyway man what is your
definition of it
so it was corporate government collusion
deep so uh
i think the official like academic
understanding of what fascism was was
ultra-nationalistic authoritarianism and
so
that could also mean you want to take
over the world but your country is in
charge of everyone else
so the the main difference i see and i
could be wrong i'm not a historian or
anything
the interest here's the interesting
thing about the communists and the
fascists they use the same symbolism
okay when they raise the fist if you
notice they raise the fist and they
point their fingers at you
it's the the fist symbol with the
fingers facing you is a symbol of all
the fingers together making a strong
unit the fist who can punch
but individually the finger was weak
that's what the f uh the f
or the fascist is that he pronounces it
that's the weapon of all the sticks tied
together with the blade in it
that individually they were together
they were strong weapon
they believed the same the same core
tenets of
banding together for power the
difference was
fascist at least today neo-fascism is
traditionalist
only you know uh the men are the ones
who work the women are in the you know
raising the kids and in the house
and antifa are fascistic in their
in their techniques and everything but
they're ultra progressive
they believe year zero culture
revolution abolish gender abolish
tradition abolish religions
so but did they the same black black
people
the same antifa people did they believe
that when they were promoting
globalism or you know uh protesting
against globalism in in the 90s
wto i don't know do you think they have
any actual real core values i think it's
new people with the same title
like the next generation they just
different people with several mindsets
my mom sent me this video where there's
a bunch of people sitting in a dentist's
office
and they're all actors a woman comes in
for her appointment and sits down
and then a bell chimes and everyone
stands up and she looks around all
confused
then everyone sits down right away then
she goes back bell chimes again everyone
stands up she looks confused
eventually she just stands up too all of
a sudden she's standing up and sitting
down every time a bell rings
one by one the people the actors leave
and then all that's left is her
bell chimes she stands up sits down new
guy comes in an actual
uh patient sits down and sees her
standing up and sitting down and he goes
what what are you doing
and she's like i just we're supposed to
do it we everyone's doing it he's like
oh so he starts standing up too
then one by one new people come in for
their appointments and then all sudden
everyone is standing up and sitting down
having no idea why they did it
amazing it just transferred over i think
what we see with the left in antifa
is it is a chaotic destructive force
with no principle
and no plan it is just the embodiment of
rage
so that's why they oppose the world
trade organization
and then now they're in favor of the
world trade organization i guess
it's collectivist i think this is
something um gosh
i don't remember this talking about it
like individualism versus collectivism
and that's really
where we're at right now um fascists and
communists are collectivists yes
you know you could say george peterson
talks about this yeah so the
collectivism it could be
i don't know if it's just dangerous in
general i think it is
because i think that individualism makes
people strong because when you have
individualism you have personal
responsibility
when you start to lose individualism you
lose personal responsibility and you
lose
like maybe this comes down to people not
experiencing the effects of their own
actions like not being disciplined maybe
when they're growing up
i don't know if that's cause or effect
but i think that the
individualism is so strongly tied to
personal responsibility you can see a
culture start to crumble when you start
to lose
individualism that's just my two cents
it's a bunch of
antifa is a bunch of kids who have been
given everything whenever they cried
about it so they're crying about it
trying to get it
i think it's funny you know uh these
college kids
uh people talk about how colleges are
indoctrinating you know young people and
i'm like
it's not in the way you think it is like
certainly there are professors that are
ridiculously woke and you know woke
walkers or whatever you want to call
them
but a lot of what indoctrinates them is
just the fact that
they wake up they're told what to do and
when they complain they're given
whatever they want
then they graduate and there's no longer
so so they're kids
and they're like i want you to imagine
now you know what a 30
a 38 year old woman with an
eight-year-old kid and she's standing in
the ice cream shop
and the kid's screaming and pounding his
feet saying i
want two scabs and then she's like okay
okay
okay please two scoops quickly he's
yelling at me oh my ears
and she gives the kid what he wants that
kid grows up
goes to college now you see it with that
video like nick christakis remember that
he's at halloween
and they're screaming like no matter
what he says they're just like shut
up that's the same kid grown up now
whose parents just said whatever you
want dear oh they're yelling in my ears
it's a lack of masculine energy in the
world i think that's it
and now what what we end up getting is
even these professors who are
respectable
are not being tough like when a
professor gets surrounded and they're
screaming at him he goes okay
okay i listen i'm listening i hear what
you're saying instead of being like
f you shut up get out of my face and
this is because the doctrines
infiltrated the top levels of the
organizations and will fire those
professors if they stand up
to the probably to the weakness because
people are more concerned about getting
that quick buck
than what's right that's another big
problem you know i love it when people
are like
i have a problem with capitalism like
you know i gotta say there is an issue
when people are like i will sell out my
principles as long as i get paid at the
end of the day
that's not an issue of capitalism though
it's an issue of
no shared values and morals
mike dropp agreed yeah yeah can you look
up the
mike tyson quote exactly i mean the
thing about it is we can see everywhere
that there's a failure of masculine
leadership there's a failure of
family there is a failure of strong
community of discipline of leadership of
accountability
and the definition of collectivism
really is that you don't it's shared
responsibility
and when you have shared responsibility
then no one has any responsibilities
when you have individual responsibility
that's when you can collectively have
responsibility it trickles up from the
individual i heard a quote
maybe it was in the seam to lab and he
said that he is like a communist
at home uh and he is
like a socialist in his community
and then he is a libertarian off in the
you know for his political views
and that is the way it is at home right
i mean dude i work
daddy works daddy pays daddy provides
i'm happy to share
it's easy peasy according you know for
me according to my ability to them
according to their needs yeah right but
i don't want to see that kind of crap at
the
the you know the federal level right
level yeah i got this quote
i'm assuming it's real this is from
world boxing news
social media made you all way too
comfortable with disrespecting people
and not getting punched in the face for
it
mike tyson i don't know if that's as the
real quote whatever i saw it going
around
it sounds like he said it i mean it's
even in the taylor swift song
which one right uh you know not this
last album but the one that came out
before where it's like something about
you know tweets in the streets it's a
knockout you know just like saying like
she gets a lot of harassment right
online and stuff and she sees it
and uh you know i felt it when i heard
that song for the first time because you
know
i get some hate out there and uh it's
interesting that you know
no it's the same phenomenon when you're
in your car right like when you're in
your car and you're in traffic
and you you're willing to like bully
somebody with your car
cut them off and give them the finger
it's because you're insulated from
real life right let me tell you
something when i am standing in line to
get into somewhere
i'm 6'4 250. how many people walk up and
cut in front of me
zero zero but people will elbow their
way in within their cars and then they
get mad at you right it's like
when people are detached from the
outcomes of their actions
like antifa has been there they just go
buck wild have you seen have you seen
the viral video where there's like a
fence
and the two dogs are yelling at each
other and barking and then the fence
starts opening it's like a gate slides
and then once it opens the dogs just
stop and like slowly turn around and
walk away like oh no now i got to be
accountable for my actions
yeah so yeah lack of masculine energy is
directly linked to
the era of social media
i think it emphasizes it but the the the
attack on masculinity has been ongoing
since the 60s
what's the why what what caused it or
what brought it on well it was the
it was when feminism decided that they
needed to
wrench the power from the patriarchy and
all
all societies are patriarchal
all patriarchies are oppressive and if
you are to end oppression you must end
the patriarchy and what is the source
of patriarchy's power masculine energy
so you have to attack it at the source
so it's very logical
because they want to do this you see
that viral tick tock where it's like
this chick is putting on makeup
and getting ready for school and she's
like y'all women in the 60s wanted me to
wanted me to be independent i don't want
to be independent and then she starts
yelling i want to be a housewife
i want to make dinner for my husband but
now i have to go to school and then she
like storms off
it's actually really funny it's very
it's funny it's
true it's sad i think the worst thing
that happened with feminism
is that they decided that the ideal
woman look like the
ideal man right instead of saying
what the ideal woman should look like
i've been saying champion femininity
i've been saying this for a long time
feminism is destroying femininity
yes because it's championing masculine
concepts for women
so you take a look at captain marvel
they're like okay we're gonna make a
superhero movie that's
traditionally a male role but women
should do it too
oh well sure but that what you're
basically saying is the ideal man is
is is paramount is peak humanity right
the point is
if you have a movie where a guy is a
superhero when he's saving the day
and then your response is women should
be like the man
instead of the man should be like the
woman you're basically saying
the men is what we should all strive the
masculine is what we should all strive
to be
but then the problem is it it it comes
down to
it's not how do i phrase this it
disinherits women
well they're they're attacking men right
because they're trying to prop women up
in masculine roles which creates which
destroys both
right that's the point i'm trying to
make exactly right exactly right by
saying that the ideal woman is
is the a man then in order to get the
women into those positions you have to
degrade the existing
man you have to degrade the existing
system in order to make
space now this is echoed in
critical race theory when it comes to
race if you've seen these these
bubbles that are like oh this is when
you're an early like a tadpole
of a anti-racist and then when you get
to your fully developed anti-racist self
it says
specifically and this was at the
smithsonian published yeah
says uh white people yield
positions of power to people of color
amazing detail specific actual
call out okay it's the same concept it's
like we need to get these people out of
power
so that we can take power thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you